en marge de cette affaire des
statistiques indiquent la petite
délinquance est en régression en france
environ 2 8% depuis le début de cette
année l'opération vigipirate déclenché
depuis les attentats terroristes de cet
été participent à cette baisse tirée
curtet eric jean jean voici quelques
cibles idéales pour pickpockets des
voyageurs un peu discret qui patientent
en détournant les yeux de leurs bagages
le lieu est propice l'aéroport charles
de gaulle si les passagers connaissent
mal l'endroit ils ne font qu'y passer
des pickpockets eux qui sont très à
l'aise pourtant ici comme ailleurs la
délinquance a baissé les délits sur la
voie publique les vols à l'arraché
cambriolages agressions vols de voitures
qui représentent plus de la moitié de la
délinquance ont chuté sur l'ensemble du
territoire de près de 6%
et puis début d'année nous constatons
une baisse sensible ces baisses
sensibles a été confortée par
l'application du plan vigipirate
c'est en effet une constante depuis le
début du mois de septembre le
déclenchement du plan vigipirate la
baisse de la délinquance c'est encore
plus net
le plan vigipirate a incontestablement
un effet bien qu'il ne soit pas conçu
pour ça le plan vigipirate c'est un plan
de prévention du terrorisme puisque au
mois de septembre la chute a été de
presque 8% et de 9 % à paris ou bien sur
le plan est activé un niveau
particulièrement élevé reste le point
noir la délinquance des mineurs en forte
augmentation près de 17 % pour
l'ensemble de l'année 94 c'est dans les
quartiers en difficulté les banlieues où
la situation s'est nettement dégradée
hélas le plan vigipirate n'a aucun effet
le pendant du renforcement des
dispositifs de sécurité est une
augmentation significative du nombre de
pv et de contraventions en tout genre
dans une interview